and that's where we will begin with
coronavirus of course because it has
been a painful 24 hours in this country
nearly 2,000 Americans died of the
corona virus yesterday that's the most
in a single date by far
this chart shows in very stark terms
just how fast we got here just think
about this five weeks ago only nine
people in the US had died from the virus
you can see how the toll is certainly
accelerated since then Anthony and
hospitals are still trying to find room
for all the patients who need treatment
our lead national correspondent David
beg no is outside New York City's Javits
Convention Center which is now an army
field hospital David what's happening
inside Anthony there are only 66
patients inside but they can hold so
many more so here's what's being done to
increase the number quickly you see
those buses behind me they just pulled
up they're picking up medical personnel
to take them to hospitals around the
city that medical personnel from the
military is going to start the transfer
process to speed it up to get those
patients here because they can hold as
many as 2,500 inside the Javits Center
the state of New York is in the middle
of the deadliest week yet around 730
people died on Tuesday alone that's
nearly one person every two minutes
behind every one of those numbers is an
individual as a family as a mother as a
father as a sister as a brother the city
is now converting one of the largest
churches in the world into yet another
field hospital but there is some good
news Governor Andrew Cuomo says that the
state appears to be reaching a plateau
in terms of hospitalizations we've been
called dr. Salim Ahmed who works in
critical care at Mount Sinai Hospital
here in New York recorded this video
diary she says she's been encouraged by
the number of patients who were coming
off of the ventilators it's sort of a
reminder of the resilience that we have
as human beings top health officials are
concerned about growing data which shows
that people of color are at greater risk
the elderly population is also being hit
hard at nursing homes around the country
there have now been 42 deaths at the
Life Care Center in Kirkland Washington
another 32 people passed away at the
Canterbury rehabilitation and Healthcare
Center in Virginia and the Elizabeth
center in New Jersey has lost at least
12 residents in Los Angeles County the
public health director now says it's
appropriate to pull loved ones out of
long-term care facilities if you were
able to care for them at home
she's definitely worried I think she
thinks this is it for her Wendy Aziz's
90 year old mother Dorothy lives at an
assisted living facility near Los
Angeles she's unsure whether bringing
her home is the right thing to do she
called her Tuesday night if you would
feel safer here we'd love to have you
here and here's hope for those on the
other side
david lac spent most of the last month
battling kovat 19 including 17 days in
the hospital six of those on a
ventilator he says he did receive at
least four different drugs the anti
malarial hydroxychloroquine and the
antibiotic azithromycin I think it's
hard to tell whether the medications
helped her work together it's very hard
to tell which is why we need more
research in this area
David's 44 years old he's a lawyer here
in New York City and he only had
exercise induced asthma is a
pre-existing condition he is home this
morning and the simple task of getting
from the couch to the kitchen he says
leaves him out of breath but Tony the
bottom line is he
is a survivor
and more than a quarter million
survivors globally David important to
highlight that as well we appreciate
that report